hi and welcome to another Collider
heroes interview I am Amy Dallen I'm
coach on drew and with us today is
author illustrator Kirk Scroggs hello so
much for joining us thanks for having me
is this awesome so you have made a new
book that coin I both love called the
secret spiral of swamp kid swamp kid
that's right Huli swamp kid swamp kid is
Russell wine right he's an eighth grader
he lives in Houma Louisiana and he kind
of has a similar affliction to Swamp
Thing he's got he's like the ultimate
outcast he's got green skin he's got
moss for hair he's got this giant tree
trunk arm
he's got face tendrils so he's pretty
much the ultimate middle school outcast
like many of us felt extremely normally
yes times 100 my favorite thing about
this book and there's there's many
things I love is how instantly likable
he is and how instantly approachable it
is and I and a lot of that comes from
the format of the book I love that it's
you're in his world like instantly or
automatically like seeing the world
through his view how did that idea come
about to read something in a journal
literally from his worldview well yeah
it was very important to me that it
seemed like it was coming straight from
the brain of an 8th grader and
particularly my brain which is pretty
much an eighth grade brain so I just
thought what better way than to have it
look like one of my actual actual
journals that I used to get in trouble
for writing when I was supposed to be
paying attention in class
really teachers would confiscate them or
you know send them home with my parents
with a little note saying yeah we're a
little concerned about your son and yeah
I wanted it to look like a journal like
it's it looks like it's written with
whatever he has on hand like a pencil or
if he has markers that day or maybe he
just has you know a bic ballpoint pen
you just wanted to look like it was
straight from the source yeah I really
enjoyed that there were scenes that had
like the timestamp and then it would be
like a cornered run because that was
middle school junior high high school a
lot of a lot of my childhood was making
those choices with a lot of manic Mad
Magazine in the in the borders like yeah
little cartoons that would oh they would
always have in the in the margins kid
all the time and like growing up this is
is this
self-reflective very yes constantly
drawing monsters
it was always Halloween my friend live
consistently the idea to make a new
character was that something he'd always
wanted to do were you a common kid
growing up I was into the like I was in
the Mad Magazine first like I said and
then any kind of spooky comics like
Tales from the Crypt or in relation to
Swamp Thing is I loved Bernie Wrightson
1970s Len wean Bernie writes and run
we've talked about a lot were yeah huge
Swamp Thing nerds you must check it out
if you haven't how young were you
getting those well at first I got the
the comic book adaptation of Creepshow
mm-hmm which he did the art for and so
that's how I learned about him and I
learned he did like heavy metal yeah
what's in heavy metal the movie which is
yeah ultimate nerdy kid but he did a
World War two bomber yeah everyone on
the plane gets shot except for one dude
and then all the others come out like
these like Tales from the Crypt ssam
bees like crawling for a mini stuck on a
bomber so it was fantastic so then I
learned that he did you know the
original Swamp Thing so I was like on
board with that for sure because it's
it's like the ultimate combination of an
EC Comics tale with like Superman yeah
it's a neat hybrid I think super heroism
in the swamp in a creature context and
of course kids love monsters yeah and I
feel sometimes I feel like there isn't
enough monster content out there that
like is accessible to kids so there's
middle grade graphic novel I think it's
perfect for that can you tell us the
story behind the project how did this
come about well DC sent out a list
because they were starting this new line
of books for like middle grade books
basically and they wanted different they
were like looking for stuff that was
already outside the box which I really
appreciated so they basically just
presented a list like we've got these
twenty characters people haven't really
seen these characters in a while or we
want to do something interesting with it
and you know Swamp Thing just
way to last month and I sent them like
within an hour I'd sent I think a couple
like or you know like my cons like three
or four fake pages I just scanned a
notebook and doodled so that was a
minute one this was yours yes yes and
I've apparently for might've heard they
liked it for a minute one but they
couldn't tell me for like two months
like my agent couldn't even like tell me
that but the hurry-up-and-wait of
entertainment are creatives it could be
the day just keep waiting things yes now
I love the creativity aspect we were
talking right before air about being
your own style of artist and leaning
into your own work how did you develop
this specific like it's really fun I
love the comedic element of your art and
the writing how did you develop that
style over time it's basically just the
way I've drawn since kindergarten just
like monsters first and then just crazy
caricatures and I love self-deprecating
humor it's just how I operate so it's
pretty much like I was telling you it
took me probably 20-30 years to realize
that that is my style yeah cuz I was
always like looking at like Jim Lee's
art or any of these great comic book
artists okay why can't I do that and
then you know someone sort of told me
it's like you do you do this you do what
you do and it's silly and goofy and it's
imperfect so I just sort of embraced
that as my style and with swamp kid I'm
hoping especially with the format where
it looks like it's drawing with pencils
and pens and on notebook paper I'm hope
being kids will look at it and be
inspired to maybe just create their own
stories with whatever they have on hand
like tell their own stories write their
own journal draw a lots of monsters
that's what I'm shooting for now the
book is out people can get it right now
have you had a chance yet to hear from
anyone who's out there in the world with
the book I have heard from a lot of like
nine year olds and yes Dave I'll give it
a thumbs ups that's like that's amazing
because what I might love it
I really appreciate the fact that this
is a mid young book that skews so
positive because I feel like there's so
much we were kind of saying how there's
not a lot of kid monster material but I
also feel like there's not a lot of
positive kid material a lot of the young
adult world is very like dystopian and
the world a very dark and this is the
opposite was that an intention when you
when you decided to do swamp kid to make
a very positive monster kid look yeah I
wanted to keep it like I mean it's got
its darkness but the darkness is totally
like Universal horror yeah you know
thrills and chills I wanted to keep it
sort of grounded based in in the world
we live in but you know sneaking some
themes about feeling comfortable and
your own your own skin and and making
friends but just just not hammer the
message it's not my style I'm not good
at it so this classic book fair but also
be taught I like that I like the kids
and everything like this is a lesson
you're receiving yeah and the dystopian
things I think it's been done any movie
theater any summer it's going to have a
variety of material out there for kids
what do you hope happens what do you
think would would be like the kid who
grows up on this book what do you hope
they do I hope they just express their
creativity as much as possible whether
it's doodling or maybe the if they can't
draw maybe it's writing just express
themselves and that's I don't know
that's my main goal you ever wanted some
wonderful side stories about friendship
in this book about here or who starts
out pretty lonely and sort of finds his
group even with some some ups and downs
along the way what was the story behind
that supporting cast or was that
something that came accidentally out of
a story or like intentional in your
planning for it I just feel it's very
important just for kids to even have
just one close friend and it that's what
I love about Charlotte in the book is
you know he might only have one really
true close friend but she's she's got
his back and I feel like he does the
same for her so it's very important and
then with Preston he's a character it's
introduced like he could possibly be you
know duplicitous he's got a TMZ
sort of thing going on like is he just
trying to exploit swamp kid but you know
ultimately I think you you realizes that
he's judged him they've each judged each
other probably a little too quickly and
then some middle school feels like and I
really like that I within five pages
like oh the paranoia is there I do
remember this exact feeling was shaping
the educational aspect important when
you're going through because i i i love
that within pages was talking about like
what photosynthesis is like behind you
like the chlorinated i love you for you
there's a lot of science in this book
and that's something that i think modern
comics are doing really well is giving
kids knowledge while entertaining was
that something you wanted to do with the
book it seemed just like i had to do it
because it's it's so gooey and gross
it's all algae and moss and swamp and
the bayou and it just seemed like guys
and and the the dr. Alec dr. Alec
Holiday Connor in trouble for that it
goes back to this scientist science is
the core to it and Charlotte is like yes
I think she basically has an electron
microscope she could just take any like
green fluid and say yes I've identified
the compound but like I was the middle
school kid in science olympiad so
Charlotte was very relatable I wasn't
that good but we can all drink you know
I was the kid doing science experiments
on himself so I definitely identified
like I ate like you do that you guys did
the thing where you made a pickle glow a
what we hooked up a bunch of those like
nine volt batteries to a pickle and it
glows because of all the accident but
then I like took a bite of that pickle
and it was I was that kid so I
definitely identified with his life
choices don't be like me in middle
school kids at we had a more fun science
class than I had before like dissecting
earthworms and I don't think they did it
after I did that I forgot the last round
what the kid ate the pickle now when you
were developing this book DC making this
this young adult style book how hands-on
was the publisher were you guys like
sending notes where they were like just
send just the book but it's done I've
got two great editors and Alex and Diego
and but they from the get-go DC has been
like this is your project
please do what you do and then
occasionally they'll they'll come back
with a note saying not too far that does
it or you know it's more like a
character that doesn't seem like
something Charlotte would do or this or
that but they've been very like
hands-off and very supportive how early
on did you know that the the actual Swan
thing would be a part of the storyline
from the get-go as this is gonna be a
Swamp Thing book as well as a swamp kid
book I did love the the in character
reference to like his adventures which
are kind of r-rated that's over there
yeah well I was when I heard they were
making a show that was like really
violent oh I better throw in a little
bit I'm sure many parents appreciate the
caveat of like no no no no yes speaking
of are you like now that you're in the
world of comics are you reading a thing
now you'd recommend for people's
anything else in the in the medium
you're enjoying my husband is more into
graphic novel so he's like they've been
lending me his library and I really like
paper girls oh good yeah they've got a
new volume of that outside bet I like
get on that and I started black science
which is really good both aren't really
for kids
black science especially adventures
elements of adventure and science yeah
and a lot of like dimensional warping
seems to be a common theme paper girls
as dense paper girls says a lot of
science then I read that paper girls one
through five twice and I was like oh
okay now it's okay fine but the
characters are very clear and accessible
and that's a different take of course on
the middle school years but viewed from
sort of a later perspective I'm where
this sort of gets at like some of the
scariness but also the the kind of joy
that can exist in that time I can't
believe I'm saying that about middle
school my favorite period of life but
maybe if I had had books like this I
would feel differently for me middle
school was great but the ninth grade for
some reason was my middle school it was
weird like so I didn't identify with
this person then I thought about wait a
minute ninth grade was basically my
rough time now is there anything now
that you've written swamp kid and you've
got your
own original character out there's
anyone else you want to write there any
other like you want to play in that box
well we are working on a new DC story
called we found a monster yes it's gonna
be monster chocked full like just
non-stop monsters it's about two kids
who find a monster it's a nice monster
but they have to protect it from society
who's scared of monsters and then as
throughout the book you're slowly gonna
realize it through through the eyes of
one of the kids that the other kid this
is not their first time at the rodeo
with monsters and there's a whole like
like guys giant layer of monsters
lurking beneath the town so yeah and all
the things that I wanted to read are
coming back like I only had dine Autopia
how to train your dragon' every two
years it's amazing yeah it really is
so one of the cool things is we're gonna
get some of these monsters are gonna be
like plucked from the DC archives like
characters who kind of see come and go
they never been like the star of the
show
just like these weird side characters
that you've seen in the past and they're
excellent and quirky little characters
so we're gonna bring them into the fold
that's perfect I love side can and
that's amazing yeah the the tiny little
characters hiding in the archives are
something that makes comic book worlds
so much fun so this sounds completely
awesome I when we when we found out
about swamp kid and I didn't know this
one thing because I just dove in and I
must want that guy I love the character
so it's really cool because now there'll
be an entire generation of kids that
will discover small things so much
sooner it's hard to introduce this
character to kids yes challenging
although I think like like you probably
the the 70s stuff being pure classic
monster stuff like you I imagine that's
the button the next best step you
probably just wait a little longer
before you get to the Ellen Moir junior
year when they discover the show
discover Alan more Simon definitely but
he's still over there so in the world of
like the comedy in
entertainment but also education I feel
like that's kind of the best gateway for
comics is this exact kind of parallel
when you're talking to these nine year
olds are you finding that they're like
reading other things or like what I'm
curious what a nine year old review is
what have the kids didn't say well we
got one today that was really good she
was just like she loved the science
aspect of it especially the Frog
specimen number two yes specimen number
two is a very delightful part of the
book that you will love
he's like a tree frog that is also
afflicted with the Swamp Thing Swamp kid
whatever is going on so he has like you
know some blooms and fly leaves growing
out of his back and he's always
producing specimen number one that's
running lowbrow joke the coloring and
this is also really specific and ties to
like the pencil type stuff was that a
conversation yet of the colorist when
you're going through or with that all
like one process I just did everything
and then they pretty much you know would
adjust the colors I guess to make sure
it looks like pencil versus pen you know
try to make the pencil look like pen so
that was probably a challenge for them
I'm sorry well it translates to one of
the most unique things about this whole
thing the world of the young adult books
is like like Hema Garcia's book right
now I love the use of color where it's a
lot of black and white and then the
color flourishes this book does
something kind of the opposite words
color flourishes on the stark white
paper so everything pops like it's
intended was that something that DC
talked about when you were developing
the book they definitely have been like
you'll see when they see something like
occasionally it'll be a page where
specimen number two has has sprayed the
page yes it's like frog green frog pee
or there's ketchup or you there's like a
page that's burned there like more of
this that's their main note more more of
this I will say as reader feedback those
parts are great because they really make
this format stand out attacked Iola yeah
next time we'll have like gross stuff on
the pages right yes texture trusty
ketchup what's the most fun part of
working on these
uh-huh pretty much the whole experience
has been fun cuz I think any author
illustrator secretly wants to draw or
write the comic for DC especially so
it's just been like a dream come true so
but anytime I got just to play around
with the part you're talking about like
mix it up with the the media I was using
or have a stain up here or that was just
like heaven playground hole-punched bits
of the pages particular favorite for me
it's very nostalgic
it's very informational I think it's a
great gateway for kids in comics it's
everything I want a kid to like comics
about so thank you so much thank you
thank you for being here you can get the
secret spiral of swamp kid right now it
is by Kirk Scroggs thank you so much for
joining us today on Collider day you
this has been a blast
I can't wait to rediscover monsters from
DC pastime so win thanks guys thanks
very much thank you